carolina morris co-owner of a
biodegradable detergent company in
cucuta proudly shows off her cleaning
products but what she's missing these
days are clients
economic hardships meant she had to let
go of 21 of her 23 employees she says
only the resumption of trade with
venezuela will save her
it is of extreme importance if not vital
for us i think this could offer us a
lifeline we could reach markets and
clients again it's a big opportunity and
we need to take advantage of it the
border between colombia and venezuela
has been closed to all but pedestrians
since 2015.
the neighbors severed relations three
years ago
now leftist president-elect gustavo
petro is promising to normalize ties and
get goods moving again
animal trade was worth more than 7
billion us dollars back in 2008.
last year it was just
155 million
business leaders hope that will change
quickly
we can regain the 120 000 jobs we lost
in a short time in just a year
and we think this is an historic
opportunity for logistics geography
costs and agriculture we could be the
venezuelan pantry for food and raw
materials we've been victims of
political fights
bitter divisions among political foes
that left the region in tatters
[Music]
this is a bridge of tienditas a
state-of-the-art overpass with three
lanes in each direction warehouses
offices and everything that's needed to
facilitate trade between the two
countries it was completed back in 2016
at a cost of 36 million dollars but it
has yet to enter into service
years of closure have also led to an
increase in crime venezuelan businesses
have resorted to buying colombian goods
smuggled to illegal crossings raising
costs and empowering criminal gangs
trade agent sandra guzman show us the
few supplies stuck in our warehouse
waiting to cross legally she says
restoring trade will take time as rules
need to be re-established
it will have to be very gradual because
we need to regain confidence before 2019
we had between 12 and 15 licensed public
warehouses for international commerce
and a duty-free zone today we have none
zero
but one thing everyone here agrees is
that reopening the border is the first
step to providing opportunities for both
sides alessandra piety al jazeera cucuta